[Music]
America's Got Talent I have to ask you
about it because big changes this year
Howard Stern on the show so you guys
mover a show to New York New York I'm in
New York how do you like being in New
York well I love the show I think the
show is better than ever I love working
with Howard Stern New York is a little
hard for me culturally to get an
activity an example of one that you the
bathroom attendants you were there for
years they have we don't have them so
much out here right in California I'm
not comfortable with another guy in the
bathroom I wash my hands and then he
hands me a cloth it's a weird job you
know I dry my hands and then and then
you have to tip them right I think
that's it so then I take a dollar and I
give a dollar and I realized I touched
money so I gotta wash my hand he hands
me a towel and then I realize he's done
it again I got a tip up so I grab
another dollar I give him a dollar and
oh I touched money so I gotta wash my
hand like broke with chafed hands New
York has been a little that's wrong on
me that's the rough time every day
probably had the video shoot while
you're washing yeah yeah
[Applause]
my dad washing his hands I can rent out
the property I love that
are you are you getting me equipment are
you getting along with Howard Stern you
guys get along we do he doesn't want me
to do any practical joke the intrusion I
think you love practical jokes then has
Howard told you that's off he said he
would kill me he said he would punch me
he said he would punch family members of
mine
if I did them so I tried you know I
tried I've been you know Ronnie the limo
driver he's got a security security guy
so what I do is I have a rich Thurber
who works with me go over to him every
like 10 minutes and go is Howard
allergic to geese and Ronnie will go why
he goes how he doesn't want me to say
and then he leaves and then he comes
back and he goes is Howard have a fear
of heights he goes why I can't say how
he wants me does all these things but I
don't think Ronnie's ever brought them I
can't imagine what's going on in
Ronnie's head that he thinks we are
planning this momentous geese filled
height peanut express again that's
perfect because you have in his
imagination it's much worse than
anything you could do well whatever it
is I'm gonna have to wash my hands you
got a couple of bucks no no he's not
gonna wash your hands it's an eclipse
it's a dude clips it's a two clips I
love that you need special passes look
at them hang in my moon they're not all
gems no not they can't be boring you
it's the nyquil it's just Eve you're on
the imei curve anyway watch a GT Mondays
and Tuesdays you call it a GT well yeah
that's America's Got Talent oh I know
that but I love
I know when people they always love in
this town to shorten the name
well htj that's me how eat the Jew
that's me
TW and this was nice this whole
interview I've enjoyed it I have to go
I'm wrapping it up now no I just want to
watch you keep going I don't have time
we'll be back I know you'll be back with
another nobody I had three minutes left
to live and it's over I have no more
stories and I don't want to sit in
silence I want you to go to a commercial
I want to go oh I guess you're running
things you're not Conan the phlegm is
about to come up please go to a break
alright you convinced me finally